Hey now I'll go one Rev my name is bird
Fat Mike fix we'll finally got updated
I don't know a free DLC alright let's
check it out
can't wait to try this it's gonna be
awesome where what's going on I'd say
wrestling pink but are you doing sir
I want that surgeon what about the bird
I'll just eat up blow ya call that make
sense
alright I know where this bomb is this
is easy enough yes suck 10 gods up on it
and we still die oh okay
and throw it in his face
what the hell is bad
Senate reference Oh
hey it's me finally hey what's up kids
but if we do it ice bro Hayate in breath
uh Austin father covers mother
all right bow gosh [ __ ] barrels okay
have five black man separate Felicity
where I was going well
yo but I haven't solved any one of them
so far as fantastic are you then let me
just call the speech all right dick best
speech ever
okay let me press this button Allah poor
Bernie
okay let me just flip drive up okay
that's the direction of a car Charlie
got that one sound but it's like a
flying but I'm like a lion flying sperm
but or some [ __ ] like that all right let
me just yep fill me up
Bob uh during my later I went nutso I
haven't told anything
all right pair 2pi [ __ ] grants in the
background uh click fit if I what if you
do oh yeah [ __ ] best [ __ ] it okay
this is officially the best game ever
right [ __ ] bet that was a solution
like Marron here alright I have to try
more of them later
I ate his hot dog and shot oh no God and
pray Madame go to female shooting lasers
i'm rainbow i just wonderful more of
that
I was the solution all right what does
he want
mcpixel for Obama
what the [ __ ] all right
stage dive all right that way then we
got the bomb and give it to Batman
hey go Batman I like your [ __ ] Batman
fine I'll give it a bird even more cool
later Bob poor boy oh boy hey boy you
couldn't just throw it up the [ __ ]
thing you got it put it on the fire
all right let's get some booze and then
fly away with our car oh I'll [ __ ] back
to the Giants but thing I was a bird
here give it to the bomb oh it's all
cute now uh-oh for a it's gonna explode
anyway [ __ ]
I'll skip the bus to this man what do we
do it
wait hahahaha so stuck in his nipples
that is [ __ ] disturbing let's give
this to the bed
ah give this to the bag take the bar
fine I'll fill the bird up here ah I
thought Oh added solves everything and
the bus is still flying back here dick
oh okay Adam Adam man I want it I want
it I want to try the more no not easy
packing I want the free DLC and I want
them all golden let's give this to
Batman
that was okay I only have mindless you
take the photo and give them to the
ballast that dude I just killers son of
a [ __ ] ah you're jumping the flames
why not
okay you take the bro oh wait you take
the photo and give some feedback see
what that does what's up to it but there
okay let's go to Gordon uh Gordon
don't take me Gordon uh wives mine the
hardest assault all right the fauna to
breath yeah you go stefana you get that
front he's gonna get all of it well done
alright don't know what I was good dance
good chance alright let's try uh Wow
amazing the hell okay
it's a creeping are using creeping on ah
oh my little pony hiya then my little
buddy get to know what about this bunny
let's give this bunny to my little pony
hey you go eat edge ah thank you thank
you so much
alright more in my little pony can okay
um here you go here's your mama up
alright I'm sure everyone would love
that
what the [ __ ] is this
Mickey Mouse what do you do Mickey Mouse
pig
come on dude all right what it's up
dudes
hey welcome you didn't like him either
you up okay that was weird
oh it's that guy with a nose yep yeah
[ __ ] girls all right it's the creeper
again let me cut some wood oh no an
apple and that what what okay this time
we will take this thing oh we found the
bomb let's give it to that this is
anything but it's the head i bum that's
fired on it
good idea Mac pixel okay why did I do
that again what about this guy he
doesn't fly up what is this
whoa holy [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill them how about looking at
you
uh.okay ever touch this
alright let's just [ __ ] take the bomb
and give it him ah and for a little
noise
alright creeper what the hell do you
want from me pick the Sun nice night now
rawr oh no oh no poor creep a pixel
[ __ ] thing okay black bear their ID
all gasp all that one cool
click the [ __ ] apples scrubber tail
or some [ __ ] kicker I don't know okay
bunny you go in here
don't question up that is just [ __ ]
nasty okay I'll take it
what else do we got let's take this
little [ __ ] put you over there it's
alright
that's nice we solve that one what do
you want
holy [ __ ] that's not everyday anything
else you can do here am i doing I
grabbed his head okay let's spit this
out over a doesn't Mike running out of
time
double head you can thank all right
let's just give this to this little [ __ ]
there you go you're welcome
[ __ ] bond traders something
yeah I do you want thank you oh it's a
Kingdom Hearts reference I don't get
that my hair dancing all right [ __ ]
love this game
goddamn I want to play there PewDiePie
map again what are you do a quick fix
but [ __ ] best thing ever
wow you should be a [ __ ] birthday all
right that's it for me today
I get very lips enjoy such a color red
today and I'll see you next episode as a
man you know I love you hahaha oh you
[ __ ] flies on anything
Wow look at them legs
there's